[Música]
ela sofre muito mais um vídeo e um eagle
mostrados uma impressora que não foi
enviada pela logitech vou mostrar
primeiro como ela funciona e depois mais
pra frente vou mostrar os três coisas
muito bacanas que eu fiz usando esta
super máquina e goiás começaram por
fazer boxe
[Música]
será esta parte a proteção percebi que
alguma coisa deu errado durante o
transporte e machucou a impressora deste
lado vejam que está assim dobrada para
dentro mas olhando bem eu acho que é bem
bonito desta forma e se diferencia das
outras impressoras ser engraçado mas
enquanto
a emissora contrário das outras que eu
já tenho ela foi quase toda montada a
única coisa que eu tenho que fazer foi
conectar os cabos de alimentação com
carlos suporta o flamengo na parte de
trás e por que colocar o vidro que como
vocês podem ver que nesta parte é
bastante rigoroso
[Música]
e vocês podem ver quem me falar nesse
modelo é muito fácil basta você clicar
em diferentes pontos
depois tem que colocar um pedaço de
papel entre o custo da linha mesa e por
baixo vocês vão ter um profundo que
podem optar ou de executar para imprimir
possa conectar a impressora ao
computador usando o cabo usb que vai na
caixinha então um cartão de memória que
também vem na caixa
eu só não gosto mais do primeiro usando
um cartão de memória mas vocês podem
também imprimir usando o vosso telemóvel
basto de carregar uma aplicação que
pronto dependendo do gosto pela moda
lona com buscar a aplicação e depois
podem carregar o modelo para aplicação
fazer o fatiamento e depois podem mandar
imprimir via wifi o que é muito feliz
eu gostava de mostrar como é que
funciona porém não tem internet no
telemóvel nem onde estou a gravar e
internet quando vou à casa e à noite
a desgostar que eu fiz com esta
impressora vou falar só duas coisas que
eu acho que é mesmo espetacular nesta
máquina uma delas é que tem um sensor na
parte de trás da máquina de passar um
filamento e quando o flamengo acaba é
magnífico em modo paulo até que vocês
mudem o filamento e depois outra coisa
que me dá muita gente já aconteceu duas
vezes é que quando a energia vai abaixo
e neste acontece muitas vezes é
impressora continua a funcionar ou seja
continua em primeiro depois
imaginem hoje foi abaixo a impressora
das ligas quando a energia volta a
impressora ligas mas fica em modo pausa
ter que vocês que carrega em play e
desta forma nunca vão ficar como deus e
nem cavaco e agora vamos aos projetos
[Música]
a primeira coisa que eu fiz foi imprimir
e subaru que já vi no cartão de memória
e como vocês podem ver ficou quase
perfeito
a única coisa que ficou menos bem foi
estas coisinhas que ficou para trás as
teias de aranha mas foi bastante fácil
de remover e vocês conseguem ver como
ficou depois
[Música]
quando tem opção para que um carro
estava fora de 50 o pequeno elástico e
prendem desta forma a segunda coisa que
eu fiz foi esse fim de assinar aqui com
a aparência de uma estrela ninja e seria
mesmo muito bacana fazer um molde é
imortal e mandar o contra coisa seja
usar o mesmo com uma estrela ninja
o problema é que não posso brincar com
fogo aqui dentro mas um dia quando
poderíamos fazer vídeo
depois eu mostro para vocês
[Música]
eu gostava de ser coisa que fiz com esta
impressora ou seja é ver seu número 3
buscar eletrônico
na primeira versão o problema era a roda
que era feita de madeira e não aguentar
um tempo na segunda versão o problema
foi esta corrente que a vida que eu ia
usando o skype está que se ia expandia e
passado algum tempo isto já não
encaixavam bem nas rodinhas
então pensei em ir bem na pista a versão
eu vou mudar a corrente por uma correia
de distribuição
então eu digo que é uma oficina e
perguntei por krohn e distribuição que
não precisa e deram muitas e eu vou usá
los para fazer vários projetos que para
o canal
[Música]
ah
ano
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o que mais você tá um charme que milita
da [ __ ] foi mal de quem quer de mim eu
estou deixando estamos com um golo após
reunir março que é de mim
[Música]
sumida
sabe o ano
[Música]
[Aplausos]
a velocidade máxima disse que teria 33
quilômetros por hora e eu vi isso
trazendo uma aplicação para o telemóvel
mas vocês vão ver que a mulher manda bem
devagar e isso é porque ela estava com
muito medo de dar mais que vocês
conseguem ver na partida em que o time
estava na mão
então nessa parte um de 33 quilômetros
por hora
[Música]
bush mirante do qual portugal usou a
casa joão eo puto falei mal de khat nem
sei lá e olha série que eu tenho que ir
à louer ao ritmo sereno ninguém esquece
de mim
luiza não é
[Música]
eu
eu era
[Música]
faltava
o barril
[Música]
em frança os cantos do fim espero que
vocês tenham gostado deste aqui se
estiverem instalados na emissora o link
vai estar na descrição do texto vídeo é
isso poderia ter sido até o próximo
mundial